by now I hope you've heard the terms
phoneme holophone and minimal pairs
you're going to need those concepts to
start examining the phonology of Latin
American Spanish we'll start with
minimal pairs which will allow us to
document the phoneme inventory of
Spanish such an inventory should contain
all major contrasting phonemes here are
five words that differ minimally bisa
base of possible Ubu so we can infer
that e-ay-e-ah oh-ooh
are vowel phonemes if we compared other
words we'd find that this holds up other
minimal pairs confirm that these five
vowels are distinct from one another and
that there isn't a sixth or a seventh
vowel beyond these five that contrasts
with them next we'll move on to
diphthongs Spanish diphthongs start or
end with the high vowel so II or ooh
here we'll find examples of free
variation since the diphthongs sometimes
have a short vowel E or ooh but other
times have a more restricted Glide yeah
or whoa cuenta or Quinta qual org well
siento or siento Gao se or Gao say if we
turn to focus on the consonants we find
many minimal pairs demonstrating that
Spanish has far more consonant phonemes
than vowel phonemes and if we keep
comparing minimal pairs we'll have a
list of how many and what kind of
consonant phonemes Spanish has at that
point we can draw up a table of all
those consonants arranged by place of
articulation manner of articulation and
voicing I'm sure you remember those
terms from the IPA for language learning
but if not head back to those lessons
for review now we have a tidy answer to
the basic question how many different
sounds does Spanish have we answered
that by finding minimal pairs Spanish
words that differ by only one sound lead
us to think that these are all different
sounds in Spanish
phonemes contrast with each other at
least they did in our minimal pairs but
what about sounds that don't contrast as
you listen more closely to Latin
American Spanish you'll notice that the
pronunciation of many of these phonemes
varies depending on context
you'll hear n pronounced em in embodies
but not in any Spanier you'll hear
Gaston but not Gaston but you'll hear
que Gaston and not Kay Gaston you'll
hear dwelling but not Whaley and you'll
hear meth wailing but not it dwelling
you'll hear Baca and not blaka but
you'll hear lavaca and not blah Baca on
the other hand you'll hear some speakers
say Chalet and others say Charley some
will say me llamo and others may yama
and some mucho but others Musha what do
these allophones suggest about the
pronunciation system of Spanish come
back next time to expand your
understanding of phonology
you